well let's ask Tim O'Toole the chief
executive of first group the majority
partner in the consortium so Tim
stagecoach the longest-running franchise
holder since privatization 21 years what
are you going to do that they did they
couldn't do well so what they couldn't
do stagecoach is a good company and
they've had a solid run on Southwest
trains but they were operating under a
different franchise different ITT
different requirements different
expectations by the government
I think this government is heard loud
and clear that the passengers want to
step up in quality so this is a first
franchise where quality is weighted
equally with price and they were looking
to see who could meet their those
requirements so it wasn't so much first
group versus what stagecoach had been
doing it's about two different bidders
coming forward with solutions and answer
to what the government is looking for
and I'm pleased that ours was chosen so
what are the big differences that
passengers are going to notice I think
we've looked at this as every element of
the passenger experience so it starts
with expanded car parks then more money
being put into the stations then more
flexible ticketing being put in
different ticketing products so we'll
have mobile barcode readers we'll be
linking up with the smart cards
throughout the franchise area and then
most importantly its new trains a lot of
new trains 750 new carriages to deal
with the commuter crush and of course we
get the benefit of the investment going
into Waterloo that the existing
franchise is overseeing with Network
Rail will be quadrupling the bandwidth
for Wi-Fi on the train so actually you
be able to use the Wi-Fi that's
advertised you know it's really every
element of the customers experience
we're going to invest it now a lot of
people say you already run the gwr rail
franchise it's being heavily criticized
in the past used to be called worse
great rest western when when you ran it
shouldn't you be concentrating on fixing
that first before going into South West
Trains we're very proud of our work on
the Great Western because of course it's
going through the biggest transformation
on the rail network as someone who's
taken the river went through the
rebuilding of the underground I know
what that is required and
things I'm proudest of on Great Western
is if you talk to the stakeholders right
through the West Country they're very
supportive of the management because
they recognize the delays to the
electrification of Network Rail it's
been something we've had to cope with
but if you look at our whole portfolio
and when we were on haul trains which
shoots the lights out in customer
satisfaction no one is even close to it
we were granted another franchise for
TPE
which at one point was a fastest-growing
franchise in the UK and on numerous
occasions cited as train operator of the
year so I would put our record of
delivery up with anyone in the industry
gwrs passenger complaints are still
running at more than twice the level
that they do on Southwest trains at the
moment and the delay in the upgrade is
also running late unfortunately we just
have to get our public our passengers
through that program but when it gets to
a position of stability like Southwest
trains has been in for a number of years
I'm confident you're going to see the
appreciation expressed by the public and
we've already start to see it I mean the
compliments we get on the new livery
we're introducing and the amenities on
the trains has been very encouraging and
that's what you have to do you have to
keep giving the public things back so
they're reminded of the value for money
that you offer
now the unions have been grumbling today
about the fact that your partner is MTR
which is pot owned by the Hong Kong
government could you have bid for this
franchise on your own why was it
necessary to partner with MTR well
actually the expression of interest we
filed we did on our own and we intended
a bid on our own
and PR approached us and we thought
about it and it made perfect sense
because this wasn't a franchise we were
bringing one big new idea it's just
about the discipline of the operation
especially in that commuter segment of
the market and I at my hat is off to MTR
with what they've done in Hong Kong what
they're doing here I mean my goodness
they're going to run the Elizabeth Line
and so we thought that it would only
improve our offer to bring them on board
and we've already benefited by their
thinking at just the discipline and
operations that we'll be able to bring
forward all right Tim O'Toole from first
group going to leave it that way thanks
for joining thank you